news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
remember that a membership at
joinedpakman.com
is the best way to help us as a country
get a fresh start here and you can
indeed use the coupon code fresh start
all one word all lowercase to save an
ungodly amount of money off of a
membership at joinpackman.com
well as votes continued and continued to
be counted donald trump decided to hold
a press briefing yesterday
he took no questions he was late his
advisors were reportedly
telling him don't do this don't do this
because quite frankly how could it
possibly go well for him
given that he had been retweeting and
tweeting for two days about
fraud it is difficult to imagine he
could behave
normally even for the shortest of press
briefings but he did it
and it was a complete and total
humiliation
let's look at it we may be getting to
the end of these for donald trump and
that would be a beautiful thing
donald trump opening with a whopper
saying if you count the legal vote i
easily win but if you count the
illegal votes they might be able to
steal it
if you count the legal votes i easily
win
if you count the illegal votes they can
try to steal
the election from us if you count the
votes that came in late
we're looking at them very strongly but
a lot of votes came in late
i've already decisively won many
critical states including massive
victories in florida
iowa indiana ohio to name just a few we
won
these and many other victories despite
historic
election interference from big media big
money and big tech
this was a lie there is no evidence of
election fraud
other than from his side trying to purge
voter rolls and have mail-in ballots
thrown out
and have vote counts stopped the only
interference we've actually seen is from
his
side joe biden throughout saying could
take a little while
let's give him time let's remain calm
trump then says that polling was
election
interference this is now alex jones
type conspiracy nonsense polling
is election interference take a look as
everyone now recognizes media polling
was
election interference in the truest
sense of that word
by powerful special interests these
really phony polls i have to call them
phony poll stake polls were designed to
keep our voters
at home create the illusion of momentum
for mr biden and diminish republicans
ability to raise
funds they were what's called
suppression polls everyone knows that
now
and it's never been used to the extent
that it's been used on this last
election
to highlight just a few examples the day
before election
quinnipiac which was wrong on
every occasion that i know of that's i
have to tell you that's the first time
in this entire race i've heard donald
trump refer to joe biden
as mr biden sleepy joe a phrase notably
absent
from this ill-advised press briefing
interesting to see that
but also the content of what donald
trump is saying
is ridiculous i also just as a little
flavor i love him saying
quinnipiac there just you know a little
little extra you always have to add a
little a little more if you're trump
trump then saying the entire election
system
is corrupt undermining confidence
at the top level mind you in the us's
ability to carry out an election and of
course
there are concerns serious concerns
about election problems in this country
but they are concerns as a result of the
things
trump's side does not the ones trump is
pointing out
and we won a case a big case and we have
others happening
a lot of lots of litigation even beyond
our litigation there's tremendous
amount of litigation generally because
of how unfair this process was and i
predicted that i've been talking about
mail-in voting for a long time it's uh
it's really destroyed our system it's a
corrupt system
and it makes people corrupt even if they
aren't by nature
but they become corrupt it's too easy
he's right i mean you you know you've
got to hand it to him
he did predict that he would do this
we knew he would do it and he's doing
every aspect of it
on monday i told you trump will claim
victory on election night even though
there won't be such a victory at least
at that time and he did it at 2 a.m 2 30
in the morning
i told you trump would claim that there
was fraud
and he immediately started doing it i
told you trump would try to get courts
to get involved
to hand him a victory and he has filed
somewhere between
four and seven eight i don't even know
the number of lawsuits at this point
so he told us he would do it and i
passed that information along to you
and he did it exactly as we predicted
then
as if this isn't crazy enough then it
gets really insane
after arguing that michigan pennsylvania
and wisconsin were rigged against him
because all the votes were counted trump
calls
for all the votes to be counted in
arizona he's blatantly trying to have it
both ways
the counting of votes was a problem in a
bunch of these states
but arizona just should keep counting
and then i'll win
and now it's getting to be to a point
where i'll go from winning by a lot
to perhaps being even down a little bit
in georgia a pipe burst in a far-away
location totally unrelated
to the location of what was happening
and they stopped counting
for four hours and a lot of things
happened
the election apparatus in georgia is run
by democrats we
also had margins of 300 000 and
michigan were way up in michigan won the
state
and uh in wisconsin we did likewise
fantastically well and
that got whittled down every in every
case they got whittled down
today we're on track to win arizona we
only need to carry
i guess 55 percent of the remaining vote
55
so really understand that he casually
says
all this counting is rigged against me
in all of these states that i
lost due to mail-in ballots but you know
in arizona you've just gotta
things look great in arizona as long as
they keep counting ballots then i'll
probably win
this is not democracy as we know it this
is a joke
this is a mockery even i don't want to
use any any kind of pejorative term but
even in the most authoritarian
uh um uh what i don't want to say
undeveloped countries but
even in countries where we have all
along
been questioning their ability to
maintain democracy
you often don't get things as ridiculous
as this from the leaders trump is out
doing even them
and then trump actually says that he's
using
tremendous litigation to stop
people from rigging the election and
there are many instances which will be
reported very shortly
there's tremendous litigation going on
and this is a case where they're trying
to steal an election
they're trying to rig an election and we
can't let that happen detroit and
philadelphia known as two of the most
corrupt political places
anywhere in our country easily
cannot be responsible for engineering
the outcome of
a presidential race a very important
presidential race in pennsylvania
democrats have gone
to the state supreme court to try and
ban our election observers
and very strongly now we won the case
but they're they're going forward they
don't want anybody in there they don't
want anybody watching them as they
uh count the ballots there is no
evidence for anything that donald trump
is saying
and when he posted some of these clips
i'm playing for you
to his twitter account twitter flagged
them
as potential misinformation about
elections
trump then alludes to pushing his bogus
legal challenges
all the way to the supreme court i'll
have the name biden on him
which is a little strange i challenge
joe and every democrat to clarify that
they only want
legal votes because they talk about
votes and i think they should use the
word legal legal votes
we want every legal vote counted and i
want every legal vote counted we want
openness and transparency no secret
count rooms
no mystery ballots no illegal votes
being cast after election day you have
election day and the laws are very
strong on that you have an election day
and they don't want votes cast after
election day and
they want the process to be an honest
one it's so important
we want an honest election we want an
honest count
and we want honest people working back
there because it's a very important job
so
that's the way this country is going to
win that's the way the united states
will win and we think we will win
the election very easily we think
there's going to be a lot of litigation
because we have so much evidence so much
proof and
it's going to end up perhaps at the
highest court in the land
we'll see but we think there'll be a lot
of litigation because we can't have
an election stolen by it like this and
so the message
is trump is such a victim everybody's
unfair
everybody's being mean they won't just
let him win
and give him another four years he needs
counts when the counts help
and he needs to stop counting when the
counting is bad
and he'll sue everyone and he'll never
concede defeat even if that's what needs
to happen
and then trump casually mentions on the
way out without taking questions of
course
that he has claimed states states that
have not actually been called for him
so it will be hopefully cleared up maybe
soon i hope soon
but it'll probably go through a process
a legal process
and as you know i've claimed certain
states and he's claiming states so we
can both claim the states but ultimately
i have a feeling judges are going to
have to rule
but there's been a lot of shenanigans
and we can't stand for that in our
country
thank you very much
[Music]
understand that trump casually says i've
claimed states and biden has claimed
states
biden has claimed no states biden is
accepting the calls of the associated
press
and state election commissions and
networks and election officials that's
what biden has done
trump is the one claiming states like
georgia pennsylvania and north carolina
which at the time he was doing it had
not been called biden is accepting
the calls of others and saying count
every vote regardless of what state it's
in whether it came in by mail or in
person trump is claiming states that
have not been called
so seriously guys this is hopefully the
last
gasp of trump anderson cooper likened it
to a turtle on its back take a look at
this most powerful person in the world
and we see him like an obese turtle on
his back
flailing in the hot sun realizing his
time is over
but he just hasn't accepted it and he
wants to take everybody down with him
so there will be legal challenges there
is the real possibility
that trump will find a way to continue
extending this and even rumor
that fox news will refuse to refer to
joe biden as president-elect
regardless of the outcome on the basis
that
his status would be challenged we'll
have more of that
but so much more to get to